coming up next the accountability hurts
we don't hurt ourselves we don't tell
ourselves the things that we need to
hear accountability means that there is
a consequence after the action I grew up
in an era where if you were a fool they
called you a fool yeah and I think we
need to bring some of that back women
cheat emotionally and men cheat because
there's a hole in the wall men have the
burden of Duty and honor put on them
that women don't the same types of men
that the older women want the same types
of men that the younger women want so
the older women are never going to give
you the game because they see you as
competition if you choose to spread your
legs open in these streets Society did
not make you do that you made the choice
to lay down with all of those men and
teach the young women our young women
are out of pocket struggling because the
older women are for the streets you're
45 years old man and you're dressing
like your daughter doing Tick Tock and
trying to show how thick you are because
you want that same 30 year old man
today's topic is are modern women to
blame for relationships today whose
fault is the dating market today
um so before we get too deep into that
I would like for you guys to define a
word that we hear so much about
I'd like for you guys to Define
accountability go here around in the
second row
accountability is being ultimately
responsible for all of your actions uh
whether it be positive or negative
yeah I would say it is accountability in
an
fixing it like you can take
accountability or know that you've done
wrong but like not pointing to the to
others and deflecting but you're
actually reflecting look in the mirror
and say what can I do to change because
that's the only person you can you can
change
I think accountability is having
introspection and self-reflection I
think it's about understanding who you
are and taking responsibility for all of
the decisions that you make in your life
yeah I would say accountability is
admitting what you did right and wrong
and then also accepting the consequences
of both
yeah I definitely agree I think taking
accountability is very important in life
and for self-development as well
I think
um self-awareness but also the ability
to receive when other people have
something to say about you because as
self we can be jaded to what we don't
see about ourselves but we don't want to
hear what other people have to say about
us and that honestly is how we co-exist
with other people and we need to be
accountable for how others receive us so
that we can properly coexist
think accountability is being honest
with yourself and that once you meet
you're at fault you can grow from that I
think that's the most important thing
so who takes more accountability men or
women men men men men men
why you're you're shaking your head
right we easily say sorry men don't say
sorry as much as women so definitely but
men say sorry and then continue to fix
it whereas women can't say sorry and
then continue to make the same mistake I
think women rarely say something I don't
think yeah across the board I've I've
never most men one of their biggest
gripes is that women they will always
move the goal posts like if they're
wrong then they will kind of
CounterPoint on how they like how you
caused it like even if they cheat well
you weren't emotionally available so
it's your fault no matter what happens
there's an excuse I rarely hear a woman
say I'm sorry honey I did wrong I'm
gonna work on it you'll never see me do
this again please forgive me well I
think that's exactly that's exactly
accountability
[Laughter]
not in all situations but I do think
women held their hands up more than men
men Gaslight that's the thing there's
accountability and gaslighting so
so um I think that there's a difference
within our society I think that women
have the privilege in our modern day
society today to not be held accountable
I did a story not too long ago about a
year or so ago just popped into my head
where a young lady went down the NBA
All-Star weekend with not enough money
to get back home she then goes on
GoFundMe in order to get money in order
to go back home men cannot do that right
men do not have that type of reach and
or access to get free money sent to them
if they make a boo-boo I don't
so
Society in general just last Quick Point
Society in general has cushions put in
place for women more often than men
that's why most homeless people in
America are men it's like 90 to 10
percent 90 yeah I think when you say
that if you if you go on the modern day
tick tocks and whatever right you'll
find videos of women saying oh how to
apologize to your man just scoot up to
him naked with your ass out right and
that shows a lot of non-accountability
that shows when you say that okay women
are more accountable it's like no that's
how they apologize they think okay if we
have sex then everything's fine and so
yeah I think women don't hold themselves
accountable a lot I think women have a
hard time having that introspection I
think if you do they try to attack
people more so than actually accept that
I think in the time though well we live
in a time where women don't really need
to be accountable in a way that men are
always running around after them which I
think needs to stop and that's why that
they never have to really held their
hands up and say look I'm sorry what
I've done wrong I'll try to fix this
because before it becomes an actual
issue the man's already there trying to
fix what they've done
this kind of listening because I feel
like in America this is not the stance
right I feel like the men that I have
come across in the dating spectrum they
are very passive they are not quick to
apologize they are very gaslighting they
don't accept accountability and to your
point about a man not being able to go
to Vegas get stuck and not make his way
back you've men these days because
they're in the streets doing whatever
have accumulated a bunch of women that
care for them you can paint her a stop
story and she's going to send you a
hundred dollars because she's caring and
wants to support you right so I think
it's a balance of each depending on the
circumstances in the person but I
definitely think women can be
accountable and from my circle in my
experiences are more accountable in this
generation of men who don't accept
accountability are not they Apologize by
actions right they just show up they
won't accept accountability for what
they did specifically a blanket apology
is not an apology if you are not owning
right that's the definition of lack of
accountability if you oh I'm just sorry
but what are we sorry for what are we
making improvements on right so I have a
question for you what was the last thing
that you apologized for what was the
last thing you took accountability for
um bad communication bad communication
yeah okay what you had something to say
I think maybe sometimes when I lose my
anger sometimes I'll blame it on other
things then the last thing I took
accountability for is when I got no do
you know what I overreacted with that
and I shouldn't have reacted in that way
so I apologize for that
can we clarify that accountability is
not the same as an apology right but
accountability means that there is a
consequence after the action so either
that means okay you did that and because
of that this is the consequence and I
believe that is what men have to deal
with I think a lot of times women think
just by saying I'm sorry I'm accountable
that is not the same thing the amount of
times that I'm in dating relationships
with different women and listen they
just want to just complain about the
problem
I want to fix the problem correct I
don't want to continue to listen to you
just talk about what happened with you
and Marianne in the office right if you
come to me with an issue let's talk
about Solutions all right okay you can't
just waste my time at like that at the
end of the day let's talk about
Solutions but I find as though a lot of
women don't communicate in Solutions so
we talk about accountability the
consequences for that is to solution if
men in general are not accountable they
will not be successful if women in
general are not accountable they can
still be the wife to a CEO and but they
can go on only fans using using that
analogy that same woman will complain to
you about you know um what happened at
work you will say as a man okay cool
what we gonna do about it what are we
doing about how are we going to fix it
how are we going to fix this she would
say oh I just wanted to vent and then
the next week or the next month she'll
be complaining to about the same thing
so it's like okay but
how would you hold yourself accountable
do you want to face this woman or
whoever you have a problem with do you
want to get it out into the air do you
want to help the situation no they just
want to vent so yeah women talk a lot
but they don't
do a lot when somebody commits a crime
do we blame the criminal or do we blame
society
I think good men can become bad where
usually when you see men that have turnt
bad I think they always started out as
good men but being around certain people
in society can change them and twist
them for them so you guys think it's 50
50. I wouldn't say 50 50. yes
if I go down the street and I steal
something is it my fault or Society no
it's your fault it's your fault it's
nothing to do with Society like if we
want to blame the system then that's the
that's the that's the Crux of no
accountability like like if you want to
just blame what my childhood my
upbringing I didn't have this I didn't
have that the same person grew up in the
same circumstance as you and they made
other choices so we have to like that's
not accountability if it's if it's
always somebody else you know who who
caused it because you were raised a
certain way I can show you the example
of somebody raised in a worse
circumstances who made better choices
than you so is it really Society if if
we can if I can point to one person who
made a better choice sorry if I make if
I could poison one person who made a
better choice then
like like you haven't your excuse is
gone but there's a moral and there's a
moral story in that so for instance if
you look at people like Robin Hood right
Robin Hood was born into a poor Society
right and what he chose to do was to rub
from the rich and give to the poor right
so was he was he wrong so I have a
question so if a guy cheats can he blame
society no no absolutely not no he has
no no discipline with his tool
why can't why can't he just blame hookup
Culture by that logic no just if you
want to hook up yeah just leave just
leave I don't understand that yeah but
it will talk just leave but I think it
also depends on your on your end goal so
like I said with Robin Hood with the
Robin Hood analogy he robbed from the
rich gave to the poor to try and change
society so so women were like they they
this woman
and these poor women out here aren't
getting enough D so he's giving charity
essentially what your example is no I'm
just talking about morally depends on
that's why I said it's depends I never
said this 50 50 I said it could also be
the society could also be the individual
I'm just saying I would say it would
depend on what you want from say so
people like if you're trying to change
society for instance look at Andrew Tate
he's trying to change society right but
he's deemed as wrong
that's why he's been jailed just people
don't like to right because people don't
like Taylor Swift as well if we're
honest but he's done things right I will
say there are moves he's made that
people are on on his side will say
listen you you self-snitched like you
you should have kept it quiet there's
moves that he needs to yeah we're
talking about that we're talking about
whether he's is that society's fault if
you self snitch is he wrong
and for what he's trying to do with him
if you self snitch you have to learn how
to move we're in the world we're in and
I'm not saying he's right or wrong what
I'm saying is that's what we're talking
about but I'm saying is but he has to
also does Andrew Tate have to take
accountability if he's self-centered but
if you if you you can you can sing about
something in a song or talk about
something on social media without it
technically being self-snitching they
have to bring evidence that you did
those exactly they have no evidence
against him so I agree with you they
have no evidence so they need to let
that go their feelings are hurt so
that's why I said Society because
Society could deem somebody wrong
because they're the ones in the room so
if I have power the original question
was about the CH about the stealer so if
I go down and steal is it my fault or
Society but let's just think if you're
if you're raised in poverty you have no
money you're in a circumstance where you
have no food and you're raising us and
you're living let's say you're a kid and
you have no money you have no food
you're dependent on parents who are on
drugs and and your your baby sister
needs to eat your mother's on crack like
there are nuances in this where you you
have to blame a portion of society that
this child has failed because we've let
them slip through the system
but how would that child eat how do they
eat tell me the solutions if their
parents are parents crack their baby
sister their little brothers and sisters
are hungry they can't get a job they're
13. I personally know of people like
this kids and homeless shelters this is
their situation Maggie understood that
wrong is still wrong there may be
reasons why this kid is stealing but we
still have to be able to say wrong is
wrong and as a parent I mean you hear it
even in parenting advice you know they
tell you oh the child is not bad they
just made bad decisions where I grew up
in an era where if you were a fool they
called you a fool yeah and I think we
need to bring some of that back because
it breeds this thing well it's not my
fault sometimes it just has to sit on
you and you just have to realize I did
that and it was wrong so is that a moral
question then like when you say wrong is
wrong because who decides what is wrong
and what is right but then the question
is well if you are let's say you're a
teenager or young your mother's on crack
there's a recent store in the U.S where
a mother left her two children her 14
year old ran away her 12 year old and
she has a three-year-old all three
different baby daddies she left him
alone in Texas is in Houston for two
months through Thanksgiving she told
them if you tell anybody that I'm
leaving that they're going to take your
little three-year-old brother away and
you'll never see him again and
threatened her so she was scared to tell
anybody what was going on her mother was
missing for two months or she was
running the streets in another state she
was left in the carrot she never
enrolled these children into school the
oldest one so she used to have to lie to
her father who was working in another
state because of course she got custody
of all the kids okay so then she because
she was threatened because the mother
said I'll never love you or see you
you'll never see your siblings again
this child had to lie to her father and
say can you please get groceries mom is
working he would call the mother say
yeah I'm working can you please send
groceries or food I'm struggling but she
couldn't tell the truth because she was
scared if that instance if she didn't
have food didn't have the father who
would who would send the groceries or
food to the house and she had to go
steal are we going to say little 12 year
old you are now accountable because your
mother's for the streets and abandon you
in your in your little sibling and now
you need consequences I think there's
even empathy for a situation but but the
whole idea is wrong is wrong exactly I
mean
and you could say this is why I did that
wrong thing and like this is my reason
for it but wrong is still wrong
it doesn't become right just because
something happened exactly it doesn't
matter well that's tough for me that one
that's a tough I think it's odd so
suppose it's for instance if I got up
and slapped you in your face right now
am I wrong yes sir yeah if you snap me
back are you wrong yes no no but
remember you made decision to slap me no
because once in self-defense
slaps you once and then he just stands
there and there's no
slap you it still
sucks
what if he slaps you and it goes sits
back down
stand up and do it again but but what if
he doesn't what if like he's held back
are you are you should you be able how
would he be helpful how do we get here
Society I'm like we've gone in the past
I think you've gone in the past I think
you
why is it that when a man cheat He
Cheats he's a cheater but when a woman
cheats she's not satisfied in the
relationship
because can we women cheat emotionally
and men cheat because there's a hole in
the wall
right that's why men cheat sounds like
an excuse me no no I'm just saying
listen it's a corn category right it's
called glory holes you see men putting
their things in they don't care who's on
the other side they're just trying to
get their rocks off right men can do
that men don't care right women actually
for a woman to cheat on a man she has to
be somewhat emotionally involved
questions back to that guy men can do it
without having any emotions yeah yeah no
but the question was different though
yeah that's not what I asked no but you
said why no I said why why does society
label the man a cheater but a woman's
not satisfied in the relationship so why
is there an excuse for for the woman but
there's not an excuse me because it's an
account no it's an accountability issue
I agree it's accountability issue for
sure listen at the end of the day um one
of the things that we open up with is
that there's
um systems put in place for whatever
reason to continue to Pander to the
modern woman and I think it's all just
kind of just based off of money I think
that if you want to sell ad placements
to the
the component of the population that
makes eighty percent of the household
purchasing decisions you're going to do
so in a way to try to make them feel
good and nice inside and avoid all
accountability at the end of the day
accountability doesn't feel good having
to fix problems doesn't feel good it's
time intensive and it brings you a dose
of reality of the things that you have
to do to over encumber that right women
don't want to do all that I just
want to just want to feel good about
themselves and let it be the man's issue
or the man's problem like again they're
not focused on Solutions generally but
that's the thing as well say as a man
you need to take accountability for
something and say you seem upset or
distraught about it there is nothing
more disgusting than a dude who doesn't
take accountability exactly it's nasty
but get away from me I don't even want
guy friends who don't take
accountability but get away from me but
me personally as a man who do you go to
to talk to about it because personally I
don't have anyone I don't know about the
other men but I know you don't have
mentors
I'm people I think of mentors but not
people that I would go to emotionally to
talk about my problems as as a man you
sit there and deal with them yourself
but I know all women mates and my Mrs
mates and so on where if they're in
trouble something went wrong whatever
and there's oh my God let me talk to
someone about this we're just about 10
15. oh if I was alive he's all right
yeah why can't you go to your father
I don't know we have this stuff no we
have a we have a great leadership he's
um he's role model in some ways but he
has his own problems that I don't wanna
you don't want to go and bother someone
else with your problem so then is it no
I I don't know my number one is my pops
if things are right like my pops
um you know he's my example of what to
be a man in modern day society today is
especially you know being a black man in
America he is my example and I make sure
that big decisions that are within my
life of things that I may not know the
answers to and I consider myself a
genuinely sometimes most of the times a
wise guy you know but for things that
you know I just can't quite figure out
and make sure that I go to him now I
know at the same time there's a lot of
young men out there that don't have that
Father Figure and actually I think
that's a large degree in a component
that's why channels like mine have blown
up is because there's a lot of men young
men out there that might have been
raised in a single parent household that
have questions regarding things that are
happening to themselves with within
their lives that they don't quite have
the answer to so I'm actually surprised
to hear that your father is as active
what he is but you don't go to him it
might be different between England and
America but from over where I'm from in
Southampton pretty much every guy that I
know would say the same as me so maybe
it's uh I don't know a difference do you
think culture are you saying that
culturally men are taught not to say
anything then
growing up in schools yet I think it was
always man up get on and do this sort
this out and I think that's the struggle
men go through and the men can actually
see what it is that's what it is what
you guys understand is that women relate
emotionally like we can empathize and so
when a woman goes through something or
she cheats we we feel this we can we try
to like bring empathy to what she what's
going on with her men are you know are
more logical in their thinking and
deductive reasoning this goes into
biology and and how men's Brains are
wired so logically women will always try
to you know there's confirmation bias as
well because there are other women so
like we we wouldn't give an excuse to a
woman who sleeps with our husband or our
man and like we got a problem with that
but if it's our girlfriend someone we
like or someone in The Sisterhood
there's this kind of like this
camaraderie men do it as well men feel a
camaraderie for each other so but I will
say overall men are much more
you know like they're gonna men are made
to to discipline men are made they're
not going to get into the emotions of
like I don't like my father I don't care
what you felt what did you do like like
quit the quit the crying quit the tears
I get it you feel this way but you have
real world consequences and I think most
women are either treated like princesses
by their fathers or they don't have
accountability growing up they don't
know what it looks like and this is why
they're offended by it and if something
happens to another woman we want to be
understanding because we automatically
empathy puts us in their shoes like we
could see how they feel because we may
have felt a certain way even if we've
never done that action but it doesn't
excuse it away they still need to be
held accountable but that's why so many
women Buck against conversations like
this because it's like how dare you say
something is all these men and men and
women cheat at almost the same rate but
yet it's always meant women but actually
Maggie I wonder what were you shaking
your head at uh yeah I mean you you said
a few things there Melanie some I agree
with I think we ended up where we agreed
but I think ultimately men have the
burden of Duty and honor put on them
that women don't and so to answer your
question as to why a man would be
labeled a cheater is because you're
supposed to do right where a woman is
coddled and kind of given well the there
there which I don't agree with we can
still empathize and still call it wrong
for example back to the other point if
I'm speeding through a traffic light
because my son is in an accident I'm
trying to get to the hospital I go
through a red light it's still wrong I
may explain the reason why but if I have
to pay a ticket for it I pay a ticket
for it where we are it's like oh I
understand go ahead and you know go
scot-free so that's what I wanted to say
what are what do you think of this
conversation I I think um
one of the things that you said is kind
of the the empathy of
um women
um and why you guys you know kind of
communicate like that and I often think
like you know I you know if I think I
like like the entrance of like a
therapist is I would say a lot more
beneficial to most modern women than
they are to Modern Men depending upon
the type of therapist that you go to I
think men should go to male therapists
but the thing is is like the downfall of
a lot of modern women today outside of
the Sims the white Knights is other
modern women that are unwilling to hold
them accountable and they'll get into
these Echo chamber circles and just
Kumbaya around the totally incorrect
thing and that's why right like I I
suggest and you know Kevin used to do it
as well too suggest therapy to a lot of
modern women because they can get a
third party arbitrator to understand the
situation and be like do you know one of
those things to be the Bearer in the bad
news however you know what's wrong you
know one of the reasons why they do that
too
competition
women see each other as competition
women never give each others the keys to
the game okay so when older women get
older right they never give younger
women the game because the older women
are actually vying for the same types of
men that the younger women are vying for
right and so you never ever tell your
opponent the key to the game you can
consult them oh my baby you're so bad is
that what you've done oh my God amazing
but the same types of men that the older
women want the same types of men that
the younger women want so the older
women are never going to give you the
game because they see you as competition
earlier Pearl and I were talking about
that earlier I want to come back to you
baby because you aren't you aren't
talking much do you feel do you have
older women in your life that hold you
accountable
um well I actually hold myself
accountable no no no no no one can hold
you you can't hold yourself accountable
because we're our own like if you don't
have outside voice we just see ourselves
how we see ourselves accountability
comes from someone saying listen
accountability hurts we don't hurt
ourselves we don't tell ourselves the
things that we need to hear you're
dating a guy you like him and an older
woman say
I see this is going on I see like this
guy is not you know that you can trust
and know that she's not competing with
you do you have an older woman in your
life yeah definitely you know um some of
my mom's friends when I was a bit more
open with my relationship they would
always like throw things at me like oh
if he does this oh he's probably
cheating things like that and it's just
I could tell you know they were in
competition and they just didn't want me
to be happy so definitely really well
it's like so they actually tried to put
your relationship in your man down did
you feel like they were trying to they
they their negativity or their negative
experiences they were trying to put on
you and him extremely negative they
would just it would just always be
something and then now I'm very very
private with my relationship and just
private with my life but like they've
never met him so it's like how how do
you have so much to say so
do you have anybody a woman an older
woman who says I love you the only thing
I want is the best for you they're not
in competition they're not trying to put
negativity they want to hear what you
have to say they want to meet him love
on him and actually get the real thing
do you have any woman in your life like
that that's older okay okay so this is a
failure
Maggie what we talked about just on her
podcast we did yesterday older women we
have failed younger women like her I'm
41. you just you're about to turn 21.
yeah like we're a 20 year difference
well you know like mothers as well I
sometimes feel like mothers in
competition with their daughters
absolutely yeah we just talked about do
you feel as though and I don't want to
put your mother on the spot or anything
you can talk in general but do you find
like what your friends or your
experience that the moms they put like a
competition they don't want you to win
because they failed yeah yeah and and
they and they will talk you into failure
right don't don't worry about it they
will console you though right but but
they'll talk you into failure and then
once you fail they'll be like oh it's
okay baby and like I said it's for it's
a if in my personal point of views for
competition about men because the same
man that is going for the 21 year old
that was the 21 year old he will sleep
with you too Melanie right yeah
in a misery loves company yeah it's like
when you when you fail a test what
what's the best feeling in the world
when you turn to someone and they're
like yeah
my class that failed
lyrical that failed I actually noticed
noted Tick Tock like it would there was
a group of like moms and they did like
the mom content and then one gets
divorced and the other gets divorced and
the other gets to it's like the whole
damn friend group and it's just like
misery really loves company they don't
want to be alone in their bad decisions
single women keep single women single
right right if the older women have not
kept their own relationship together
then it's really hard to wish that uh
blessing on someone else I think you
have to be very selective and find
someone that is in a relationship that
you actually admire and they're secure
in that relationship I think if you're
trying to get advice from older single
women that's where it can really go live
but sometimes married women as well
because how many married women do we
know wish they could be back in the
streets right that's miserable
I know so many who are just like they
see the glamor of being flown to Dubai
and they don't know they're getting
flown these single and get flown to
Dubai because they're laying down with a
camera you're getting flown and blown no
no no they've flown and blown that is
what is going on they're actually
selling but we don't because what
happens is younger guys that you may be
what's the oldest guy you've dated
well this is my well second boyfriend
and he's 23. okay yeah so he's not that
much older yeah but that same 23 year
old will try to
will sleep with and go after someone my
age is he serious this happens every day
but I say to myself like so what happens
is these older women will feel like okay
well that little 20 something year old
she can't do nothing for you boo let's
come over here and I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna put it on you she's not grown
she's immature this is how these older
women are thinking these cougars and so
they see you as competition instead of
loving on you and wanting you to win or
they'll use shaming language like
calling the dude a pedo when it's just
like no he just likes younger women yeah
it's and but when they were younger
creepy or he's crazy I don't know a
single older woman who when she was
younger did not date an older guy but
once they get older it's like oh well I
was naive then I didn't know and all
this other stuff so like yeah I dated an
older guy but it's it really was abusive
and I'm just thinking to myself will you
really abused dating an older guys
Financial abuse credit card right they
feel that way and and that's why I
wanted to talk to her because I said as
a younger woman like you know this is
our whole conversation Maggie we were
talking about this yesterday about older
women are competing for the same men
they don't realize that the older women
think because these men will your
boyfriend I'm not saying he is but your
boyfriend will sleep with a woman who's
older and so they think they're in
competition with you and they have to
prove this but they should have been out
the game a long time ago you can see in
The Tick Tock videos right when you see
like mother and daughters right and the
mother looks quite young
that's your competition right there and
it's like the mother's trying to keep up
with her yes but on the flip side men
like MTR men like myself right we may be
older we're trying to give younger men
the game we're trying to say look young
guys this is what you do this is what
you don't do right this older guys what
I've realized older guys don't mind
giving younger guys a game they won't
they don't mind telling them where they
went wrong okay I don't mind telling a
young the guy where I went wrong do you
know what I mean well and generally
generally dudes if you're in competition
of another with another dude usually
it's more brute strength fruit uh you
know in competition physically uh
downright to fighting status financials
uh generally women compete utilizing
manipulation innuendo uh reputation
destruction we're not giving you the
keys to whatever it is that you're
trying to do right because women don't
generally fight just based off of right
like physical power s but there's other
things that they do Wonder right women
aren't holding each other accountable
but it also sounds like we aren't
holding men accountable right that they
are able to go and do these things with
multiple women and attract to that right
so why are we so why is that our
standard I have a question so um are you
aware that one one in three men are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year yes given the weight that
women date and things like that yep what
percent of men do you think are sexually
active in sleeping with multiple women
hmm
I think it's like 30 or 40 or something
it's it's way less it's five to ten
percent yeah so it's like you're gonna
put five to ten percent of men's
decisions on all of all
on all of men when really it's like 80
of women that are sleeping with them
amen that's it so I'm saying women need
to take the accountability right so so
it's who's it more on women for sure
that's what I was posing that women
aren't holding women accountable but the
men the five to ten percent of men that
are out doing that they're doing it with
all of the 87 and we aren't holding them
accountable but the women should they
because the women are throwing
themselves right like Drake like what
these girls are these girls are waiting
wrong is wrong right no no no no no no
no
you can't hold Men wrong for developing
themselves to be as best as what they
positively and ultimately can be and
then they get all of this coochie thrown
at them okay the concept
concept of groupie is a strictly female
term it's not it on the flip side right
so like I I think like listen at the end
of the day there's a whole media engine
put in the place to hold men accountable
I don't want no scrubs scrub is a God
for me
[Music]
come on come on and on top of that on
the flip side they got the women singing
about being Miss Independent I don't
cook I don't clean all of these things
that don't hold them accountable for
being a good marriageable wife
same women though are actually wives or
want to be wives but they're telling us
like I don't cook I don't clean them for
the street city girls the city girls are
talking about we're independent but then
you're so desperate for a man the
benefits of being modern and not the
consequences of being modern they want
the benefits of being modern and the
benefits of being conservative or
traditional at the same damn time while
a whole media engine is have been
holding men accountable since TV was TV
since love connection was on the goddamn
TV screen and all up until today the
music the TV not YouTube because we hold
them accountable over here and every
other forms of media the movies the
Disney they've been holding guys
accountable since the beginning of time
to talk shows shout out to Steve Harvey
shout out to the Derrick Jacksons y'all
been holding guys accountable now we
have platforms today where men can hold
women accountable and y'all get mad at
us
men or women oh women so then wouldn't
you say it's women's fault for giving
out sex for free so let's not get this
confused I am a hundred percent that
women are not being held accountable at
all right but it we there's a balancing
factor and why can that coexist yes we
aren't holding each other accountable or
things like that but there's still a
standard of a men allowing that that we
aren't hold accountable but it's not the
only thing that I'm saying but that's
the only thing what we've already proven
is that it's not the majority of men it
is a five to ten percent that women are
choosing to give their bodies to and lay
down with do you know there are between
18 and 30 there are I I think the
numbers three times the number of men
who are virgins then there are girl than
women who are virgins women can run
through body count and run through I
mean I did a a video where I talked
about how I read women's body counts
like women
anonymously business women these are not
women they're strippers and for of the
street they actually gave their body
count there was a 29 year old woman that
had 150 plus and she said I wish it was
higher oh my God and even women who had
low body count low numbers of men they
said it should be higher they actually
feel embarrassed like I should be living
little and and I used to feel there was
there's no shame about it if you ask the
same men unless they are certain looks
they have a certain amount of looks or
money in status they can't get the
average woman if if all of us women went
outside right now and was just like
listen
come back to the crib let's go to the
car let's go to the alley I'm gonna bust
it down for you I'm gonna give it to you
we can rack up the whole city we can
rack up all of London and one
but a man if they can go outside even if
they look good even at the status they
still have a level of work they they may
be on a good night could maybe get two
if they are just really really really
have sex with who they want men have sex
only one of them changes the outcome of
their relationships in the future I mean
I'm not I'm not gonna say that it has no
impact but which one has significantly
more if a man sleeps with 100 100 women
can he settle down I would argue still
yeah but what if a woman sleeps with a
hundred man she men she can't women men
care about quantity women care about
quality of the women so if I see I'm
like that's your ex-girlfriend that's
who you slept with uh like if she's like
a bus stand or I know she's a known hoe
or the dude just slept with processes we
would be upset as women a man will care
about the number of men that she has
slept with we care about about the
quality because we're almost like that's
why that's why if a girl if a man has a
other women around him who look good
other women around him that look good or
his girlfriend looks good he's like
pre-qualified we're just like oh he's
got a baddie it in US it incites like
he's pre-qualified whereas we care about
if we see a good looking guy with like a
girl that looks terrible we're like he's
probably broke he's probably this I
won't want him a man doesn't care about
that all he gives was quantities what
were you gonna say but to the point
right it's 80 of women who are out here
doing these things it's five to ten
percent of men who are sleeping with
them but they are running through the 80
percent of women and now they are
disqualifying them from being good good
wives so it first needs that's the
choice
so women are opening their legs you just
said that women control sex how would
the 80 of men just running through these
women
accessibility needs to start with the
women and locking that down and not
doing that right so then the five to ten
percent of men who are running have no
place to go right that is
all the accountability because all the
women are sleeping with that five to ten
percent so we need to women need the
accountability the five to ten percent
it like like so we're sharing like no
I'm sorry the majority of men do not
paying accounts that's not women if 80
of women are choosing these five to ten
percent ma'am you have not you
sweetheart I'm just talking in general I
know when I say ma'am I'm just talking
so I'm just saying like how are we going
to blame men when it's five to ten
percent that's getting 80 percent of the
women out here it's us women if five
percent five to ten percent of women
were choosing to sleep with those five
to ten percent men let them go off and
do their thing but we have women in Mass
the majority of women that are giving
themselves to these low quality tyrones
pookies and ray rays that don't really
that don't care when those good men that
are right around you but you don't want
him because he's corny you know only one
influences the outcome of your
relationship like the man sleeping with
multiple women it's not going to
influence the outcome of his
relationship but it sure as hell is
going to influence the outcome of hers
for her future husband we know so that
makes it okay though but we live in a
time where we can watch all of these
Tick-Tock videos with these Street
interviews and the guys are asking girls
about what have you done what's what's
what have you got to confess and these
girls are saying they've been ran
through they've had five guys in one
night and we've now got to the point
yeah we've got to the party no you do
not believe that sex outside of marriage
is wrong
so yes but yeah but do you still partake
yes right so in modern culture it's it's
relevant right and you're blaming
culture I'm not blaming culture that's
just what that's the reality right now
because yeah right but that's yours an
individual you have individual
accountability I don't care what culture
is doing I make a choice with my box
culture is not going to give me STD
culture is not gonna give make me I'm
culture's not going to take care of when
I have a um you know I'm an unwed mother
culture is not going to take care of
those things I am responsible for my
body my my who I give my body to I have
soul ties to if you choose to spread
your legs open in these streets Society
did not make you do that you made the
choice to lay down with all of those men
and you can and putting it on it many
Tech accountability you chose to bust it
open for that F boy or or that Pookie
that is your choice
however I'll say this go off when your
Society tells you that something is okay
so what we've seen within the next we've
been the past 10 years is a spike in
people that are calling themselves
non-binary and trans right we've seen a
spike in it why because the society has
said it's okay to be that way that's the
choice right it is that it is their
choice but I'm saying we have to
understand that when society says
something is okay it has an impact on
individuals like this is the reality
because there's a reason why you don't
allow your children to watch certain
things on TV right
the society impacts you you live in
society
you're children to watch certain things
on TV there's a reason why you don't
allow your children to go around certain
people why because as much as you could
teach your child and say don't do this
that's wrong right your child can still
be influenced right by a certain group
of your choice even as a child it's your
choice who you surround yourself with
like I remember being like a kid and
thinking these girls were mad right and
thinking these girls were crazy and it's
like even even as a child you have some
accountability for the the friends you
choose to surround yourself with but
what where does accountability come from
it comes from the influences it comes
from our society and all I'm saying is
we can't discredit no no
accountability
I don't agree accountability comes from
yourself and the ability to take where's
that shape from them
every woman every woman that has laid
down with the five to ten percent man
there is another woman who was raised in
some of the circumstances or worse that
made a different decision so that's
where your accountability is because you
can have all the excuses a society
everybody all of this but there is
another person out there that made a
different and a better choice just
because you were born in that then you
have to say why did they make a better
choice and I chose to do this so if one
person in the world made a better choice
than you then you have to say Society
didn't influence them Society didn't do
this why am why am I so weak why am I so
unaccountable that I want to blame
everyone else if one person has made a
better choice than you then you need to
rise to the cream of the crop but so
many of us are at the bottom we want to
be like everybody else we want to be
regular we want to be at we want to be
below average and we don't strive for
excellence in anything that we do
creates Society I think we're missing
something the one percent of men do who
know I'm saying like who passes on
culture in a family exactly and then
yeah one thing that that's missing is
talking about the individual and we're
talking about Society we have completely
neglected the home and the family
because was I would argue that if an
older woman had told this younger lady
or any younger lady that this is how
boys see you if you do that you would
act differently if someone had told you
that I think men do a much better job of
checking each other because men see
themselves in younger men
women see themselves as younger women so
a man bars she's good you better teach
ERS
a man looks at his life in phases he
knew he was a boy he knew he was a young
man he knew he was you know a bachelor
and then he's like I'm ready to set it
down a woman doesn't do that a woman
still thinks even though I'm 40 or 50 or
whatever I can still twerk like a little
girl I can still wear revealing clothing
I think there's some Sierra
I would say what men build societies
women pass on the culture typically yes
they do and so by that by that logic if
the culture is bad whose fault is it
the women and the who's breaking up
homes men are away the whole word right
there so and and if if we're if we're
growing up in a family that doesn't in a
society that doesn't value family whose
fault is it no I think that's women I
agree they're breaking up the home we
actually done something on that and I
actually said uh if the woman's not
right because she's the first teacher of
children right so if the woman's not
right the society is not going to be
right because if you're the first
teacher of the children as women you
spend most of the time with the children
so if you are the one that is constantly
and consistently around the children
then the child's not going to be right
and the Childs are the ones that go out
into society
I think I actually heard you said oh
before that's the thing in single mother
homes that's when kids do bad you always
deemed a father figure in the home to be
able to coach and teach the child how to
be disciplined and accountable in life
there are some though in single months
we have these outliers like LeBron James
single mother
um you know family and even his wife
Savannah James that's how I brought her
her up if you saw her a picture of
Sierra and you put a picture of of
Savannah James at the Oscars
Savannah James Every Woman across the
board like people are talking about
that's my wedding dress like she's
inspired me she is she is gold she is it
she was a single mother very young she
was raised by a single mother LeBron
James so even even if you raise a single
mother poverty all your circumstances
look at people who made different
choices if they made other choices you
have no excuse if somebody else came out
of your sisters and let's be honest
right now ladies and gentlemen
everything we're talking about right now
is very lightweight and weak if we look
at history and what people have gone
through in real struggle and what we
call you know hardship and it's not my
my choice look I mean you look at the
society as a whole throughout you know
all of Europe Africa and everywhere we
are living in a time of of absolute
privilege and so when we when we in the
accountability that they had to take
that it is just even this conversation
is is is spoiled and it is privilege and
it is very we don't know hard work we
don't know what it's like to really
struggle so we can even have the luxury
of having these conversations like this
and and and and it's it's it was life
and death for a woman to lose her
virginity to the streets okay it was
life and death it means you would be a
destitute you were actually sent to the
brothels if you aged out you know
because you did not marry at a certain
age you were sent to work in the in the
Brothel House changed right and so it
now it's only fans and so and and
Instagram so what we're seeing is even
these conversations we really as a
society now don't know accountability
and I mean if we really want to go there
but overall I would say absolutely the
onus is on the women to pass down the
culture teach the young women our young
women are out of pocket struggling
because the older women are for the
streets many of them you have women who
are in their 40s still being IG models
getting bust down and flew out flute
flewed out is what they call it and just
doing the most and looking like
strippers what we call even cute outfits
today sexy this is what you know I don't
know what I'm gonna say the word but
like women of uh uh ladies of the night
would wear in old times and there's no
accountability you're 45 years old man
and you're dressing like your daughter
doing Tick Tock and trying to show how
thick you are because you want that same
30 year old man but because as your
daughter can get you can get the same
man he'll be in let's say he's 33 you're
40 your daughter's 20. he's 30. you're
trying to get that man because you're so
lost and so consumed into yourself you
have nothing to teach but old box but I
think that's the reason why men are
supposed to be the ones leading Society
exactly right and I think that's the
reason why
um because we like I said discussed
earlier on women are not going to give
younger women the key to the game it's
just not going to do it it's competition
they're not going to do it sitting
around asking and expecting them to do
it you'll be waiting a long time for
them to do that right so it's for
mentally Society so when you talk about
Society about Society has been
fragmented and it's been broken so now
men can be women and women can be men in
the whole thing's Topsy Turvy and upside
down and so the reason for society being
this way is because men aren't allowed
to lead men like TMR men like myself we
get called misogynistic do you know what
I mean when we try to lead we get called
all types of Earth doesn't say so if if
you're Dusty then say so if you're if
you're gay then say so we get shame and
for trying to be leaders as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible